does testosterone lower for all men  after 40 or other dietary things you can  do to increase it or is it just going to  hit everybody it definitely starts to  decrease actually even by like 27 or 20  it'll start to decrease slightly and  then by 40.  so it's not just women it's not just  women  women also have testosterone just like  men do that's where a woman's sex drive  comes from as well you know i do have  some women who take a low dose of  testosterone not only just for their sex  drive but also just for their general  energy and motivation and kind of just  sounds kind of fun it's going to  increase yeah make you a little more  argumentative yeah and probably a little  bit just more like general confidence i  guess you could say and then if you have  more it's wonderful sounds like you're  gonna want some